foreign
so this is every morning I get up I will
usually first thing I do is I I put this
shirt on it's a you can see it's pretty
old now I got it off eBay years ago and
it's like a fleece it's just a fleece
pullover if you're listening to the
audio version of this it's just a fleece
pullover and it's rather worn and I not
claiming this is the only shirt that I
own and it's also not the only shirt
that I wear obviously I'm wearing one
right now in fact we have a drawer full
of like three or four of these long
sleeve shirts so that when I come in
here I just take this fleece off and I
put the odd casting shirt on like a
superhero basically you don't wear the
same podcasting shirt every day that's
true I don't want the fleece you wear
the same fleece I wear the same fleece
every day but I also wear I have other
shirts I'm not saying this is the only
shirt that I own right it's like me
listening to Christmas music every day
it's not the only thing I listen to but
Christmas is getting some love every day
yeah I guess this is my Christmas shirt
yeah I just wear it every day of the
year and it's just a super comfortable
shirt it's almost like a a um
security blanket in a way I just really
enjoy wearing the shirt and here's the
thing people often I'll walk somewhere
and they'll say oh it's such a nice
shirt and it's so beat up and Raggedy
and like but I wear the same shirt every
day and I thought about having this
discussion with you because did you
remember the meme Jordan that
went out with uh matthewvella he made a
YouTube video and he was like I wore the
same shirt for 900 days in a row or
whatever and then the meme that was up
on Reddit we'll put it right here above
my left shoulder here if you're watching
the video version of this it was like
it's a picture of like a woman I think
walking into her closet she's like I
have nothing to wear and then it's like
men I wore the same shirt for 900 days
in a row
but this just conjures an image of one
of my friends who I was first when I was
first exposed to minimalism her name's
Nina Yao she had a Blog at the time
she's a yoga instructor in Chicago now
uh super talented writer and just a
wonderful human being and she was
working for a company and the story that
I remember is
she was tired of being that Meme whereas
I had nothing to wear and so for one
year she went into her corporate job and
wore the same exact outfit every single
day of the year and it wasn't just a
basic black shirt like this that No
One's Gonna notice it was a bright red
sweater it was Christmas
but she wore it every day in the entire
year she wore it for one calendar year
and one person mentioned it once I
didn't you wear that yesterday and the
truth is
as much pressure as we think we feel
yeah we think everyone's judging us and
everyone wants us to change and I need
to impress everyone no one's really
paying attention and for those who are
paying attention if they really want you
to wear something different
is that someone you want to be
allocating your time and attention
toward anyway do you worry about them
earlier in this episode we were talking
about Rob Bell's idea of death by paper
cuts right yeah because what happens
here we
I'll get nine compliments oh that's a
great shirt that's a great yeah I really
like your haircut whatever it is right
and that's all fine right yeah but as
soon as you get that one little cavil
even if it's framed in a way something
else Rob Bell calls it he calls it a
chocolate covered turd
because what happens is what it's like
oh TK even though I really dislike your
haircut I really enjoy your podcast
right wait what I'm not thinking about
how you enjoy my podcast I'm thinking
about how you hate my hair cut right
yeah yeah and enough of these paper cuts
show up again and again and again and
they make us feel miserable over time we
it's traumatic to deal with tiny little
paper cuts and Cavs from everyone all
the time and being worried about that
and one way that I don't worry about it
is I literally wear the same shirt every
day now thankfully I don't know Mal have
you ever seen me uh smell funny when I
walk into the studio at all she's not
even near her mic I don't know where she
went get back to your microphone
a smoke break over here no I've never
I've never noticed that you smell funny
if I did I would tell you there you go
thank you I appreciate that see we have
an honest relationship here but I don't
I barely ever even wash it which is I
know it's strange I I don't sweat nearly
as much as Nicodemus does
but I wear it every single day it
doesn't mean it's the only shirt I wear
I don't wear this to the gym I have a
t-shirt that I'll wear to the gym and
shorts that I wear to the gym it's not
the only piece of clothes that I own but
I wear it every single day and it's
comfortable but at the same time if it
were to spontaneously combust I'd be
completely fine without it man you just
make me think about all the different
ways that we limit ourselves and what we
really want to do because of arbitrary
narratives that aren't even going to get
us anywhere anyway you know like oh I
don't want to wear this shirt even
though I like it and it's comfortable
and it's my favorite shirt because uh
people are going to think this is the
only outfit I wear and maybe people
aren't going to think about you at all
and even if they do think about you
what's more important you feeling great
about what you're wearing you feeling
comfortable and at home in your body or
someone else having a comment about you
wearing a shirt two days in a row I mean
I I have a friend who he'll do things
like when he goes to Starbucks he'll
like have a big um like jug of protein
powdered protein with them or or he'll
have like a big like a gallon of uh like
water with him and he just he just
breaks social rules like that all the
types of things that people like oh I
can't just bring that with me or I can't
take this or I can't do that and he just
does it and no one ever bothers him no
one ever says anything so it's kind of
funny your shirt makes me uh think of
that like what Freedom would we feel if
we allowed ourselves to just do what
feels free without worrying about the
narratives that says no no no you can
never do the same thing twice I I used
to do this by the way with my teaching I
I don't know where I picked it up
probably for my upbringing in church
this idea that spontaneity equals
spirituality and so I always felt like
if I told the same story twice that
that's a bad thing because it's not
spontaneous and therefore not spiritual
and so I would put pressure on myself
that whenever I'm teaching if I've used
an analogy before or used the story
before I can never use it again because
that kills spontaneity can you just
imagine how much that compromises your
ability to be effective yeah did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free